babylon 5 the expanse even stargate all
delayed because of the stream in war
welcome to side trek your sci-fi tv and
movie channel
so if you are a regular sidetracker
first of all you'll know that i speak to
a couple of people that work in and
around mgm one of those sources doesn't
actually work directly for mgm but he is
kind of an accountant that works with a
company that works directly with them
um he's not really an accountant so it
takes a little bit more complicating
that but one of the things he does do is
he works a lot with contracts and things
like this but he also does and works
with a lot of research people people
that crunch numbers for these big
companies like mgm
i've been talking to him in the last few
weeks and he has been telling me a lot
about the war between the streaming
services
hbo max paramount plus netflix disney
plus and of course amazon prime
one of the things he was telling me was
that in 2019 2020 when the lockdown
happened there was a massive surge in
subscriptions
we were all stuck at home with nothing
better to do so we all subscribed to
streaming services
on average people in the united states
have at least three here in the uk it's
two or three
however now in 2022 we've all gone back
to work we've all got less time
and we've also all got less money
because the thing that actually drove
all of that massive investment and all
those huge surge in numbers
is now the thing that is plateauing that
growth
because we've got less cash in our
pockets thanks to the cost of living
crisis and many of us are trying now to
decide which of these services we can
get rid of if you are new to the channel
by the way please like subscribe hit the
bell notification it really helps us out
and you become a fully fledged side
tracker consider hitting the join button
so what does this mean for our big tv
shows the ones that we're really excited
about returning like babylon 5 the
expanse and stargate
well let me tackle the expanse first
series 6 ended
and
even though they said series six has
ended for now it was never actually sort
of like officially killed it was never
really officially
cancelled
they just sort of said it's gone on
hiatus the producers of the tv show have
said it's very possible the show could
return some of the actors have made
little cryptic comments about it
possibly returning and if you are again
a regular side check you know i've done
videos about how amazon really have
thought about different possibilities to
this show
now nothing is set in stone yet and
these are rumors but
people that work in and around mgm told
me that they saw plans for possibly
three movies but that apparently got
scrapped quite quickly those three
movies would have covered the next three
books that wasn't gonna happen they
decided that they could never make these
books into movies it just wouldn't work
and definitely not for the budget they
were considering
the next idea was to create um just
actually move forward with series seven
there's a thirty year gap between book
six and seven now there are ways they
could get around that
but generally it was decided that maybe
that wasn't the way to go but there is a
plan in place right now my sources tell
me that there is an idea to actually
have a couple of spin-off series but but
why would you have a spin-off series why
would you move away from the books as
the series has quite closely stuck to
the book so far
well
amazon producers and amazon executives
think that the expanse has never done as
well as it should have done it's a
better show than the ratings suggest it
does win awards
but it never gets the big draw that
they've always wanted
so one way of maybe getting new viewers
is to have a spin-off series a series
that can be pushed as a new sci-fi show
but that is still linked to the expanse
something that would please current fans
but maybe draw in new ones
that is the current plan now it hasn't
got any further than that being outlined
as an idea and as far as i know no
showroom has been approached there are
no scripts in place this is just a plan
for the future
but even that plan is currently on pause
it's on pause because of the reasons i
was telling you about the streaming
services
amazon though have got it even worse
they spend about 13 billion dollars a
year on
content music movies tvs
one billion dollars nearly of that has
been earmarked for the lord of the rings
now when you've only got a 13 billion
dollar budget for a year earmarking so
much to one project has had an impact
also amazon prime has actually run a
loss over several years they've been
trying to win this this streaming
service race and trying to create more
and more content
the plan was for 2022 and 2023 that they
would at very least break even that
doesn't look like it's going to happen
for amazon a slowdown in subscription
numbers would be a big problem they were
projecting to hit 300 million
subscribers over the next five years now
those numbers seem very unlikely
so because of this slowdown and because
of the
pressure on our bills we are instead of
having two or three subscription
channels probably i'm going to have one
or two
disney has had a massive increase in
subscriptions over the last two years
and disney plus has very quickly become
the main stream in service hbo is
merging with discovery that's going to
make a real juggernaut of the streaming
service
really the main competition for disney
plus in the united states netflix has
been having a very slow decline over the
last couple of years as other streaming
services and more competition has really
pressured them and they're just not
getting the content they once did
amazon prime has always been sort of the
third or fourth runner-up but has had a
massive growth for the last couple of
years driven a lot by having its
subscription linked to amazon prime and
getting free delivery on our stuff that
we want to do on lockdown so just to
summarize because of the slowdown in
subscriptions and the slowdown in growth
because amazon believes it now is
overspent on lord of the rings and that
lord of the rings is actually getting
massively criticized online even though
there's a show that's not been finished
major and we haven't seen yet lots of
people have already said this load of
rubbish i don't really understand that
but amazon look at things like that on
social media
and even netflix has spent a lot of
money on the last airbender series and
that is also perhaps at risk because
it's maybe even though it's costing a
fortune to make might not actually get
them the viewing figures they were
hoping for
because of these reasons all of the
streaming services are currently looking
at their budgets except for maybe disney
plus
they're all wondering how do they get
more for their money
all of them are very nervous what the
next 12 months might bring and the
insider that has spoken to me has
basically said that that means for the
next 12 months there's going to be
significant uncertainty
if they are not absolutely certain a
project is going to succeed
it may not get green lit these people at
the end of the day are human and in the
last six months they've been made to
feel a little bit nervous
the mgm sale through to amazon is a good
example of this mgm were promised by
amazon that they were going to be left
to be autonomous
amazon are now saying after
two of the top executives left that
actually mgn will be absorbed into
amazon prime and that nobody expected
what happened with kovitz nobody
expected tv and movies to basically be
shut down for a year and these are the
reasons why all of its promises over the
last 12 months are not going to be kept
so it is uncertain times ahead and it
looks like the first victims of these
uncertain times are going to be babylon
5 which was going to be moved over from
the cw hbo max we're now not sure what's
happening with that
a possible expanse series or spin-off
series we're now not sure what's
happening with that
and the return of stargate the last of
which being something that looked almost
certain just a couple of months ago and
now
we can't be so sure
even though i'm absolutely certain these
projects will happen at some point
the insider that i've spoken to says
that he doesn't expect any of these
things to be greenlit or any new major
project to be greenlit in the next six
months possibly 12 months so
please guys get into the comments tell
me exactly what you think about this
news um i'd love to know as well how
many streaming services do you actually
subscribe to personally i subscribe to
four god i subscribe to four
oh i really need to get a life
but
how many do you subscribe to and
you know what do you think about this
thing that amazon is saying that they
weren't really expecting covered and
that it's only really now suddenly we're
feeling the effects does that feel like
an excuse to you because i gotta say it
does to me
if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification it really helps us out
you've also considered becoming a fully
fledged side tracker hit the join button
finally if you love the t-shirt i do i
really like this t-shirt and there's a
link in the description psytrek.com that
you can go to and buy loads of lovely
merchandise
including a bring back stargate t-shirt
jumper whatever else
as always guys please stay safe i'll see
you soon
[Music]
you